Very good afternoon everybody.
Um,
I want to talk a little bit about the last six years off my life and how it
happened that I came to India.
So first of all,
I want to show you a small video that shows the environment in which I spent the
last six years of my life.
Yeah,
okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
So now the question arises,
why,
why did I live,
uh,
my job,
my family?
Uh,
a good life in the capital of Germany,
Berlin,
uh,
to live in a tiny little remote village in Raja,
Stan,
uh,
to coach and teach the children of the village.
I was always very adventurous.
I love to travel and I come from a very sports related family.
My grandfather,
my grandmother,
my uncle,
my Auntie,
my mother,
my father,
my whole family was engaged in the local sports club.
We all grew up in a volunteering in the Sports Club,
in coaching and playing different kinds of sports.
And so it was in my blood and I am what I am today because of sports.
Um,
I started my own travel agency,
uh,
so that I could travel all the time.
And,
uh,
one of my favorite destinations was India.
I was always traveling around looking for new places where I could bring my
clients off the beaten track to show them the real country.
My business partner came from Jaipur and his mother came from a little village,
which was halfway between Agra and Jaipur.
So we thought it would be a good idea to bring our clients for a lunch break to
a little Indian village,
show them the real village life,
traditional life,
colorful life,
and a host them for a lunch break are maybe the kids of the village could show
their village and the local family could have some extra income.
So the family lived in this,
uh,
ruined Ford.
They were the,
uh,
former rulers,
the rush foods of the village.
And,
uh,
I started dreaming of maybe I could teach them some hockey.
The village kids,
they have nothing to do.
And uh,
maybe we could have some space in front of the Ford where we could start
coaching.
So I shared my dream with the local family and they will say,
yeah,
you can have the space in front of our Ford.
We don't use that and you can try.
So in 2010,
I was hosting a veteran's hockey team from Vienna,
from Austria,
and we brought some hockey sticks and we had a training session with the kids.
And um,
so the kids were so excited and then I started dreaming that your,
this would be a great story if I,
if I could make a difference in that village.
So obviously my business was still in Germany and uh,
I could only coach them once in a while when I was in India.
Otherwise,
uh,
nothing much happened in the village.
So I tried to hire volunteers from Germany who could bridge the gap,
uh,
when I was not here,
but that somehow didn't work out.
Then I thought,
okay,
maybe I could run my travel business online and I could sit in that village.
Maybe I would have less clients than before,
but I would need not so much money to survive here and I could coach and teach
the kids.
So I gave everything up in Germany.
I sold everything.
I closed my office and a reconstructed two rooms in that old fort.
And uh,
I called a roller and attractor and we leveled the ground here in front of,
uh,
the fort and be called the kids for practice.
I went to the local schools and I wanted it to especially encourage the girls to
play hockey with me.
And uh,
I brought sticks and I coached them for a training session and I invited them to
come in the afternoon after school,
uh,
to our hockey ground.
And I also try to offer them English classes because I didn't speak Hindi,
they didn't speak any English.
So the mode of communication was very basic.
There was a old temple and uh,
the family provided me one room,
which we use just an open air classroom.
And I started giving English classes where some of the kids would show up in the
afternoons.
But I realized that,
you know,
that traditional Indian schooling system with kids happily repeat what you tell
them what their brains are not working anyhow,
that doesn't work much and they don't learn anything.
So we started,
uh,
speaking on the hockey grounds.
So actually all the kids learn speaking English while playing.
This was our village hockey ground.
We made a boundary wall around and it was very dusty,
especially during the hot summers.
It was almost unbearable,
but the kids would show up every day and they didn't mind.
And,
uh,
so we had a kind of time sharing agreement with the local cows,
which would rest on that place while we were not playing.
And so the kids always tried to sneak in late because the first one who came had
to remove the remainings of the cows.
And,
um,
so yeah,
we had so many kids that I could not,
uh,
make,
like get hold of them and they were very wild.
So I started learning the colors in Hindi and I bought tee shirts in different
colors so that I could say the Biela group is there,
the Lal is there,
and it's a fetus over there.
And I got some older students of the village who helped me in coaching in the
beginning.
So I try to make them understand and also for me,
uh,
don't dream your life.
Live your dream.
So then after one year practicing,
uh,
I showed them the movie check to India.
They got very fascinated.
That was a funny story because,
um,
I bought her old screen and a beamer and invited the kids to watch with me the
movie and you know,
bought,
we brought the cables out of the Ford and there was some power cuts obviously
also.
And uh,
we had to show the movie when the sun was almost going down so that we can see
the movie and we put some chairs up and kids were sitting on the ground and I
was fascinated watching the movie and I was so excited about my idea.
And after half an hour,
I looked around and only the farmers were sitting here around me because the
kids already went home because when,
when it's getting dark,
they all have to go home.
So yeah,
so they only saw half of the movie.
Nevertheless,
they got very much inspired and they said,
Andrea,
you also want to play.
So my friend,
he was the hockey coach and the DPS,
a school in Jaipur,
and they invited us for our first match.
So we went by train to Jaipur,
which was already the first big excitement.
And I feel so privileged I could share all these first moments with the kids.
You know,
they saw the big city,
they asked me and the rear hole do go Obera like how,
how they can go up these huge buildings and how there's all this traffic works.
And uh,
the first time in their life they were wearing sports shoes,
shin pads,
socks.
So,
uh,
John Do,
my local partner and I,
we was sitting next to each other.
One was putting up the socks,
one was putting inside the Shin pads and then be sent them on the ground.
And the,
the whole stadium was full with a privileged children invite school uniforms.
The green grass was,
wow.
They've never seen such a grass in their life.
And we realize that,
uh,
you know,
we were quite malnutritioned compared to the city children,
which were according to the coach,
the same age group,
which I don't agree.
But yes,
this was the next lesson that we had had to learn.
Life is not fair,
especially when it comes to sports and competition.
I had to learn my lesson the hard way in India.
If it's under 14,
it's maybe under 70.
So then I thought,
uh,
my project needs more awareness.
I need to raise funds so high,
I'm going to do this.
So I have to roam around the country.
So I bought a wig shop and I drove from j port two tonight,
2000,
400 kilometers in 30 days.
And I can tell you it was the best way to know the country.
Every hundred kilometers,
different de different food.
Um,
the people were so friendly and welcoming.
I had to,
I had to drink chai with each and everybody.
Everybody wanted to know like,
what the hell is that white woman doing in [inaudible]?
And we had a two meter hockey stick a on the roof.
Um,
so we'd be promoted.
I mean,
we didn't raise any funds to be honest,
but it was a great experience.
And we were in some newspaper highlighted and uh,
you know,
there was some awareness of the project,
at least it was a great experience to drive all along the country.
Yeah.
So it,
I try to encourage the kids that you have to sit in the driver's seat of your
car,
of your life.
Uh,
it villages,
they are only driven by the village society,
by their parents.
They do what they,
what the parents want.
And uh,
uh,
later on they do a job,
which they don't want,
but the parents wanted or the neighbors want other whoever wants but not them.
So sports teaches you to be self confident to understand what you want in your
life.
So then obviously the girls also wanted to play and my focus was anyway,
on the Gus,
uh,
the problem was just that they're scored any forms.
The skirts were quite long,
so it was very difficult to run.
And a regular hockey skirt would be very brave for a village girl to wear that
was too short.
So then my fashion design diploma came into,
uh,
accounts.
So I got,
uh,
tailoring machine and I tailored hockey skirts,
which were a little longer then a,
the regular hockey skirts and the girls loved them.
And I always had my silver suitcase where I put all the socks.
She embeds just a shirts and skirts and we would travel with the train.
This time we went to Hariana and the girls had their first match.
But,
uh,
that was again a very enthusiastic from my end because it was,
I think it was April made was like 40,
45 degrees.
It was burning hot and we had to wait for them at Dt,
which is more important the longer you have to wait.
So the first children already fainted because of the heat.
And,
uh,
we finally had then our match.
And um,
this is,
uh,
my daughter Cavita so I took care of her.
She didn't have a mother and I brought her the best Puma shoes from Germany and
she said under the two tight,
she wanted to play bare feet.
She was the wired Jangle Kitschy,
wanted,
uh,
to play bare feet as per her convenience and not with my good sport.
She was that I brought for her.
Then,
uh,
we played our first all India,
Katie Sing Babu under 14 tournament,
which is by the way,
the only under 14 tournament where really under 14 team sampling in Lucknow and
they had a really,
really good sports canteen.
So in Roger,
Stan,
most of the families are vegetarians and it's even you're a bad person if you
are a non vegetarian.
So I'm from Germany,
I am a non vegetarian so that was always some blame to put on me or a bad
influence that I have on the children because I'm eating non which,
so this is [inaudible],
he was our goalkeeper,
he was the smallest of all and he saw all the other teams eating eggs for
breakfast and butter and everything.
And he was asking me and the year if I eat eggs I get strong.
You can try.
So he was,
he went to the buffet,
he got one egg.
The whole team was watching him.
He survived the egg and all,
all the others.
One by one also took one egg.
By the end of the tournament everybody had four eggs for breakfast.
And since that time it was always our secret.
If we went out for tournaments together,
the first question was and three of eat omelet.
So they knew that this is something good but they are not allowed to eat this at
home.
And somebody was even asking me if his mother can smell that he eat eggs
there was literally scared.
So we always extended most of the time we were out in the first round on
tournaments because we were the youngest.
But to get more experience,
I always ask the organizer if we can stay some two,
three days longer.
First of all,
you travel all the way for one match and then the food is so good and they don't
get that kind of food at home.
Plus if they watch matches,
they also can learn a lot.
So we always extended are staying.
We had lovely food everyday.
This was the narrow cap in daily where they together with all the state teams,
we're doing the march pass and you can see here our hand painted flag and the
kids were thrilled.
They flood light book,
astroturf.
ASTROTURF in Delhi.
Wonderful.
Yeah.
So if you have a dream,
sky's the limit.
Then,
uh,
the next,
crazy thing I did was I imported a secondhand astroturf from Germany.
And,
uh,
it was quite,
an action because it was the first,
second hand astroturf that came to India and nobody at the customs knew how to
handle that,
how to evaluate a secondhand as sort of from Germany and how much tax I have to
pay.
So after I overcame this,
the huge drag with the astroturf turf came from good shot at port to register.
And we had a huge party and I thought like,
wow,
my dream is coming true.
We haven't astroturf.
I made it happen in Roger's done.
There are only two asset person.
I have number three and I can make this happen for these children.
And we had a huge party and it was nice and great.
And the next morning,
eight o'clock,
Saturday,
one of my girls called me and she said,
Andrea,
please,
you'll come to the ground polices there.
There is a problem.
Okay.
So we went to the ground,
the ground where it was already going on.
It was a government project and the sports ministry sanction money,
everything was Nice,
huge stones blocked the entrance,
the Sour Punch was sitting there on a plastic chair and around 300 villages with
a singing freedom fighter songs and glitchy go home.
Today she's ruling the hockey ground tomorrow she's ruling India.
We don't want history to repeat itself.
I thought like this,
are they talking about me?
What does that mean?
Truly the hockey ground.
I signed that this astroturf will be government property and I donate to the
community.
All I want is that these kids can play on an astroturf.
So I had to load my astroturf again,
rescued to another place and store it somewhere.
So the dream of the [inaudible] was on hold.
Then I thought,
okay,
if my kids cannot play in Rancho Santa Ana Astroturf,
I bring them to Germany.
So I took five boys for two month in the summer holidays to Germany where they
stayed in German families for two months,
had lovely German food and uh,
played in a German club.
And surprisingly,
they could compete with the kids or their age group and they got so much
exposure and so much learning for their future life that nobody can ever do for
them in their life again.
So they came back and everybody was thinking that maybe,
maybe they don't want to go back,
but they were so bonded with their families and their,
so we're so proud to tell all their stories and bring all the chocolates home
and in all benefit from their experience and tell everybody and uh,
motivate or the other kids so that there was a big battle for the next year that
who would be the privileged ones who could come with me to Germany.
So since that time,
every year we select some children,
the best ones who are present in practice,
good in studies,
good in hockey and good attitude,
good discipline.
And we take them to Germany and we find a lot of sponsors in Germany who support
this hockey clubs,
who hosts them and who find this a very great idea to integrate them in their
teams.
So Deepak,
my so called son,
he was the lucky one.
He even went with me to Switzerland and he was so amazed that these cows give 40
liters of milk while he's buffalo at home,
gives maximum one liter,
which is enough for a cup of Chai for his grandfather.
Then,
um,
I thought,
okay,
sports is good,
but I should involve myself more in education because that is what counts at the
end.
And I'm out of that old temple.
We made a school.
So I had German volunteers with me and with our own hands,
we knocked down walls and ceilings and the whole village was standing outside
watching us how these white people can do this labor work,
which is actually the lowest level of work that you can do.
And we were working hand in hand with the local laborers who earned like 250
rupees a day.
And we had a lot of fun.
We had a lot of fun to build a school with our own hands.
And we started the first English medium school with,
uh,
our little ones.
So I want to show you a small video from our school,
how we tried to teach the village kids and a state of the art way.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Okay.
So our school was a primary school,
English medium,
Elica [inaudible] class one,
two,
three,
and four.
Unfortunately.
Uh,
we also had to shut down that school,
um,
April of this year because our local partner misused foundation money and,
uh,
we bought land to lay out that astro turf where you saw that where the kids were
playing.
We already made a concrete base to final delay or that,
uh,
astro turf.
So the dream was a little closer.
Um,
but,
uh,
the local partner registered the land in his name and we had to file a big case
against him.
And the result was that he was threatening all the children and um,
was beating them up in school.
Uh,
whoever came for practice.
So out of 80 children who were daily therefore practice,
uh,
who played for the district,
who played for the state,
uh,
nobody was allowed to come anymore.
Um,
we didn't get any support from the parents.
And,
um,
we were raising the question that,
uh,
you know,
we can only work and continue if you stand by our side and if you understand
what this project is all about.
And only one family was standing up and they were even from the neighboring
village.
Uh,
so we decided to leave this place.
We got threatened for our lives and,
uh,
there was no way to continue.
So we got an offer from Cork where there is obviously more awareness about
sports.
Um,
and we thought that maybe we have a better start there.
Uh,
it was a big decision to,
you know,
get all the energy again together and all the motivation and overcome,
uh,
the bad experience and struggle and loss,
that we were facing and registered and start again.
But we said,
okay,
we do it for the children.
And,
uh,
we packed a truck with all our belongings,
mainly hockey equipment and school equipment and we have two Labradors.
And so my husband and I and the two Labradors,
we're in the truck and for 70 hours and 2,400 kilometers,
we were driving from jet water and Roger Stone to cook to set up a new hockey
village.
And uh,
since three months we are working with the local primary school grade one to
seven.
We coached them in hockey and uh,
we teach English and math for grade one,
two and three.
They're all children from the Labor for the,
from the coffee plantation laborers.
And we hope that we can make a difference there.
Again,
I still believe that we made a difference in Retro Stan.
We left our footsteps behind and um,
we took three of the children with us,
uh,
each 15,
16 or 17,
she Vonnie got selected as the first and only girl from Ron has done for the
national academy and she is playing at the moment a senior nationals at the age
of 15 for other Stan.
And I hope she has a bright future.
And um,
uh,
Rohit is from Gore.
He lived with me the last three years in a row to Stan and I took him now to
cook.
He has a learning disability.
He's a,
I'm suffering from legacy so he can't properly read and write.
But he's a brilliant Sportsperson,
a brilliant,
excellent cook.
And he's repairing each and everything.
He's making bamboo rafts and he's the king of the jungle and cook and Deepak,
he's 17,
he's also very good hockey player.
And he became our plumber and electrician because we live so far away in the
jungle that even if you call her an electrician or a plumber by takes 10 days
until somebody comes.
So he's keeping our activities alive by making Jugaad here and there.
And uh,
yeah.
So we brought these three kids from [inaudible] so this is what we could take
with us.
And still kids are calling us and asking us like,
when do you come back or do you open a new school?
We want to come to your school.
So at least for the children,
I think we made a difference and uh,
we want to continue the same thing in cook.
So that is Shivani.
She came as the first girl to Germany two years back and she played an excellent
seasoned for one of the best clubs in Germany.
And so now we are thinking if we are going to bring her to Germany but we don't
want to miss out any trial for her because you never know when any selector is
spotting her and inviting her.
Because last year the trial for the national academy,
she didn't manage to get a space because of all the struggles that we had in
retro style.
She didn't practice for some time,
but now in cooled we trained her well and she's fit and we hope that she has a
bright future and will one day play for India.
So she was very easy going.
The coming from a village the first day,
uh,
in Germany,
she was very,
the hot pants of her,
uh,
German sister.
She was completely adapting to the German lifestyle,
which is very surprising,
but I think that gives her a really bright future because she's very open
minded.
Her English is pretty good.
She's doing now and our s means open schooling.
We teacher at home and she's doing that in English.
All subjects she's doing,
she's doing bio and chemistry and English,
and this is British.
He was three times in Germany and he got a job with the Thyssen Krupp elevators
in Jaipur,
even if he only has a Hindi medium,
12th grade pass.
But he was so motivated and Thyssenkrupp said,
okay,
he's so brilliant.
We take him.
Unfortunately,
his parents thought more of a government job and didn't allow him to take the
job.
Um,
well,
let's see.
Maybe he will fight his way through,
but he is a very,
very bright and brilliant,
uh,
child and he will make his way,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
So they will be a day in your life when you look back and what you did in your
life and didn't make sense.
Did it make any impact?
Did you make a difference?
And that was actually my motivation to start this project and to go ahead and
ahead and ahead,
because I think I cannot forgive myself if I stop because I think I can do more
debate and encourage so many more children.
Thank you.
[inaudible].